las tortugas marinas son milagrosas en
primer lugar nos acompañan desde el
jurásico tardío hace unos 150 millones
de años compañeras de los dinosaurios
han sobrevivido al desafío de los
tiempos cuando muchos otros han
terminado su carrera evolutiva en
segundo lugar a lo largo de los siglos y
hasta hoy cada adulto de tortuga marina
ha superado todos los pronósticos y hoy
existen producto de la casualidad la
destreza y la capacidad a lo largo de
sus vidas las tortugas se enfrentan
varios retos primero son depositadas en
forma de huevos del tamaño de una pelota
de ping pong en un hoyo excavado por su
madre en la arena de esos 50 a 200
huevos un 20 por ciento nunca saldrá del
cascarón un mes y medio después de haber
puesto los huevos los supervivientes
eclosionan y las jóvenes tortugas tan
pequeñas que caben en la palma de una
mano salen en masa a la superficie desde
la arena en una carrera desesperada
hacia el mar en el camino los escombros
las trampas los cangrejos las gaviotas y
otras amenazas terminará
con un 50 por ciento de las que
emergieron de la arena y las que
finalmente llegan al mar en realidad
solo cambian un peligro por otro ya que
primero enfrentan la barrera de las olas
y luego encuentran nuevos depredadores
que las esperan como peces
el fin es tiburones y las aves marinas
cuando salen a la superficie para tomar
aire en sus primeros días de vida en
caso de estar entre las vivas las
vulnerables tortugas nadan
frenéticamente hacia adelante a menudo
se asentarán en restos flotantes sobre
todo en restos de algas en los meses
siguientes tratarán de evitar a sus
depredadores encontrar que comer y no
caer ante las presiones del clima o las
corrientes marinas en esta fase un 50
por ciento de las que llegaron al mar
morirán a la larga con el paso de los
años las sobrevivientes aumentarán de
tamaño pasando de ser del tamaño de un
plato a ser casi tan grandes como una
mesa al menos en el caso de una especie
la laúd después de aproximadamente 10
años su tamaño les da cierta protección
los unicos depredadores verdaderamente
preocupantes son algunas
especies de tiburones como el tiburón
toro tigre y blanco y algunas orcas al
cumplir unas dos décadas las
sobrevivientes tendrán edad suficiente
para reproducirse y continuar con el
ciclo necesario para su propia
existencia de aquellos huevos puestos en
una playa lejana ahora quedan menos del
10% o al menos esa era las
probabilidades sin contar con una
intervención humana significativa en los
últimos siglos y en particular en las
últimas décadas la acción humana en
forma de construcción en zonas costeras
residuos plásticos caza furtiva líneas
de pesca químicos nocivos incluyendo el
petróleo se ha vuelto una amenaza para
las tortugas marinas haciendo caer la
tasa de supervivencia a un 1% o incluso
menos en cada ciclo de anidación es esta
presión humana añadida lo que ha llevado
a 8 especies de tortugas marinas a estar
amenazadas o en peligro de extinción
desde hace mucho han evolucionado para
superar una serie de obstáculos pero el
más reciente ha surgido tan rápidamente
y a tal escala que las especies se han
visto abrumar
repasemos rápidamente este ciclo de
probabilidades en una temporada
hipotética de anidación las hembras
pueden anidar varias veces en un año y
para simplificar digamos que ponen unos
mil huevos de ellos unos 800 eclosionar
400 llegan al agua 200 llegan a ser
adultos y sólo 20 consiguen reproducirse
y eso sin interferencia humana si
añadimos la interferencia humana sólo 2
llegan a la edad reproductiva así una
tortuga marina en reproducción es la
encarnación misma de una casualidad es
la excepción no la regla es una lotería
y en cierto sentido un verdadero milagro